Il me e.
- On est revenus, revenus,
revenuu cégep, on en
parlait encore, ça n'arrête pas.
- Assirègles d'accord
des participes passés relève
souvent du parcours
du comE DUMAINE, v.-p., Asso.
Québécoise des prof. de français
ropose une réforme
qui serait capable de travailler
cette notion-là.
la prola prola prola prola prols
années au Québec et a même
été suggérée il y a plus
d'un siècle en France.
L'Association québécoisequi regs
de membres du primaire
à l'université, veut abolir
les exceptions et réduire
les règles d'accord
Avec l'auxiliaire "avoir",
par exemple, le verbe serait
toujours invariable.
- Et on pourrait prendre
le temps de, au lieu
ces exceptions-là, soit d'aller
travaires notions
grammaticales qui en avaient
besoin.
selon cette enseignante
de français qui aide les élèves
en difficulté depuis
une quinzaine d'années.
CATHERINE PARADIS, enseign
- Le réel problème c'en est
un de littératie, à mon
les jeunes ont de la difficulté
à lire, à écrire correctement
la langue française. Puis,ssés
dans tout ça, c'est somme toute
assez anecdotique. Donc, j'ai
rien crd-là, qui est
ivement complexe, mais
ça ne règlera pas tout.
- Chez les étudiants,
l'idée de réforme divise.
- On dirait que e juste
de l'enlever, je me mélangerais
beaucoup.
- Ça aiderait, un petit peu, à
simplifier l'affaire, puis
réduirurs de français.
- Ce serait une question
de tolérance, mais pas
ne cette linguiste en
faveur de la réforme.
de linguistique, UQÀM
- Les francophones font de moins
en moins l'accord du participe
passé avec "avoir" à l'oral, et
donc il est donc tout à fait
- Au cabinet du ministre
de l'Éducation,
Jean-François Roberge, on répond
qu'on va étudier la demande
de l'Association québécoise
des professeurs de français
et qu'il est encore trop tôt
Ici Olivier Lefebvre,
Radio-Canada, M